hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on apex legends again today
we have some new info to talk about a
teaser from the apex legends Twitter
account themselves talking about a new
weapon coming tomorrow which put quite
possibly could be a new energy weapon so
as always like the BP do enjoy the
discover for new I cover the
informational side of a pax legend so if
you never miss an update so if you never
do want to miss an update definitely sub
stay subscribe to the channel and with
that let's get started with today's
teaser video so first up just from the
teaser it seems like we're going to be
having an energy weapon in apex legends
I'll play the T's are on screen a couple
times and of course throughout the video
and then go a little bit more in depth
first the first thing though I do want
to apologize for the quality because
going fullscreen on Twitter thumbs down
the quality a tremendous amount
especially on the desktop and there's
actually no fix for that so I do
apologize but check the clip out right
now
that judging from that my thoughts that
this is going to be a new energy weapon
based on the blue energy on the form of
the gun
I think it's an energy gun since one of
the gun like I said it shoots the blue
energy bullets and I believe energy
weapons don't get enough love I think
the only energy guns we have in the game
are the devotion and the triple take and
they aren't really used as much as
compared to other ammo types at least
from my experience when playing and I've
put a lot this past week and at the end
it shows a player sliding and I think
this is him charging up the gun this
could be very similar to the precision
choke that the one that the peacekeeper
and the trip will take has or maybe
that's an attachment that is compatible
with it so maybe you get to use the
precision choke on the triple tape the
Peacekeeper and this new weapon or it's
something that automatically comes with
the weapon we'll have to see when it
comes out tomorrow it also seems like
it's going to be a fully auto gun
judging from the beginning of the teaser
with the possibility of maybe having a
short burst like the hemlock or a single
fire like the g7 except my bets are
probably gonna be in the g7 single fire
type ammo as the secondary but the title
of the tweet is a bit interesting it
says get ready to cry havoc a new gun is
coming to King's Canyon from the recent
leaks a new weapon coming soon was
actually called havoc the exact way that
it's spelled so personally to me judging
from my theory I'm convinced that this
weapon tomorrow is going to be an energy
weapon that can be using precision choke
called the havoc like I said I think
it's gonna be an energy gun just because
I feel like they don't get enough love
and I really feel like they do deserve a
lot of love because the triple take is a
solid gun and same with the devotion if
he's correctly Lemon a dots in the
comments down below guys this is only
gonna be a really quick video but if I
did happen to miss something in the 9
second teaser that should be brought up
definitely let me know in the comments
below so that everyone could be up to
date on what everyone thinks this new
weapon is gonna be called and also let
me know your thoughts about this book do
you think it's going to be an AR an SMG
is it gonna have the energy ammo the
heavy ammo what do you think the charged
up thing in the beginning air at the end
of it is or is that just some [ __ ]
that I'm overlooking but yeah with that
guys like the V if you do enjoy a
subscriber for new I cover the
informational side of apex legends that
being the balance changes the new legend
updates the new teasers like this the
battle pass all that stuff I'm going to
cover everything for apex legends so if
you never want to miss an update
definitely stay subscribe the channel
and with that guys and my two most
recent videos would be on screen if you
guys do want to check that out I think I
survived great stirred a think for watch
the video let me know your thoughts in
the teaser and peace out
[Music]
you